The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
We are on the finish line.
Two more weeks to go.
Our last chapter is coherence,
and I can promise you
this chapter of coherence
has some highlights,
so we are not going to
and more boring subject.
Actually, some of
the best subjects,
some of the most exciting
topics are still to come.
So today, we continue our
discussion of coherence.
As I pointed out
last week, we first
talk about coherence
in single atoms
and then coherence
between atoms.
In the first part
on coherence, I
want to come back to this
topic of spontaneous emission,
because many of us have
deep rooted misconceptions
about what spontaneous
emission is.
We discussed on Wednesday that
spontaneous emission is not
so spontaneous as many
of us assume because it's
a unitary time evolution
with an operator
with a term in the Hamiltonian.
It is exactly this
operator which
takes the wave function of
the total system, the atoms
and the light, to
whatever it is later on.
There is no random phase,
there is no random variable
in this time evolution,
exclamation mark.
But there are certain
aspects associated
with spontaneous emission,
and I want to address them.
On the other hand, if you think
about spontaneous emission
in the most fundamental way,
the first thing you should think
about it, vacuum
Rabi oscillation.
Here you see in the
simplest possible system
what spontaneous
emission can do for you.
The way we want to discuss
an important aspect
of spontaneous emission, we want
to go beyond the vacuum Rabi
oscillation, is the following.
We start with an atom
in the ground state
and the cavity is
in the vacuum state,
but now we take a
short pulse of a laser
and we prepare the atom.
And because the laser
outputs a coherent state,
the coherent state has
a well defined phase,
and this phase appears
in the superposition
between ground and excited
state because this superposition
is created with the
matrix element which
has the electric
field of the laser.
But then we allow spontaneous
emission to happen,
and spontaneous
emission to happen
means we take our operator
which I just showed you,
we propagate forward
in time in such a way
that we just go through half
a cycle of a vacuum Rabi
oscillation, which
means everything which
was in the excited state
is now in the ground state.
And by just exactly propagating
this system forward in time,
we obtain this state,
and that's something
I hope very, very
insightful which
we arrived at the end
of the last lecture,
that the quantum
state of the atom
has been perfectly mapped
onto the photon field.
So all the information
which was in the atom
before spontaneous
emission is now
available in the photon field.
So the next thing to
address is the phase phi.
What is the phase of the
spontaneously emitted photon,
and this is what we
want to understand now.
So how well can we
measure the phase phi?
You should first assume
the phase phi is perfectly
determined with
extremely high accuracy
if you use a laser
beam which has
a macroscopic electric field.
The phase phi is a
classical variable
and can be determined
with arbitrary precision.
And therefore the phase phi,
which we have imprinted first
into the atomic wave function
and then in the photon field,
is an exact number.
It comes from the laser beam.
What I'm showing here
is phase space plots
for the photon field.
I know we talk about
photons and two
dimensional phase-space
distribution mainly in 8-422,
but I think the pictures
speak for themselves.
A lot of you have seen the
harmonic oscillator and
harmonic oscillator,
if you start
to prepare the system here, this
is position, this is momentum,
the system evolves in a circle.
A lot of you have seen, if we
regard photon states as states
of a harmonic oscillator,
which they are,
that you have flux states,
which are just circles,
or the vacuum state is just
a tiny circle at the center.
And if you have
a coherent state,
a coherent state is maybe
a little blob out there,
and for the coherent state,
you can determine the phase
because the angle of this little
blob relative to the origin
is well determined.
I think you all have
seen a version of that.
So anyway, what
is done here is I
show you this phase-space
plot for the photon field,
and what happens is if
initially, the excited
state was zero, this is
just the ground state
of the harmonic oscillator.
It's a circle.
If the excited
state was occupied
with unity probability, it's
a flux state with n equals 1,
and here you see the phase-space
plot of a flux state with n
equals 1.
And of course, you realize if
you have exactly one photon
or one atom in an excited state.
There is no phase
information left
because the phase is
actually the relative phase
in the superposition between
ground and excited state.
If you have an
excited state, only
an excited state
with a phase factor,
you know if a phase factor
can simply be factored out
of the total wave function,
it's never measurable.
What is measurable
are phases which
are relative phases between two
amplitudes which are populated.
And of course, not
surprisingly, if we now
vary the excited state
fraction of the atom, that's
a probability to have a
photon in the photon field
from zero or one in
between, we sort of see
that this phase-space
distribution, it
points along the 45 degree axis
and we can measure the phase.
And the most accurate
phase measurement
can be done if the superposition
between ground and excited
state is 50-50, or, talking
about the photon field,
we have a 50-50 superposition
state between no photon and one
photon.
But the phase here is
indetermined and the phase here
has quite a bit of
variance because if you
have a single photon,
there's only so much accuracy
for the phase.
It would require
more discussion,
but sometimes you talk even
about an uncertainty relation,
delta n delta phi equals 1.
So if you have one
photon, you can only
measure the phase with
precision on the order of unity.
If you had millions
of photons, then you
can do very accurate
phase measurements.
So what we have is-- let me
just summarize the conclusion.
So the phase phi is best
defined in the atom,
and therefore also in
the photon field, when
we have an equal superposition
of spin up and spin down,
of ground and excited state.
And you also get that from the
Bloch vector picture, if you
have a Bloch vector which
is pointing like that,
it doesn't have a phase,
it's just pointing up.
If it's pointing down,
there is no phase.
But if it's a 50%
superposition state,
it points in the xy plane and
you have the best definition
of the relative phase of
the amplitude between ground
and excited state.
So I mentioned this Heisenberg
uncertainty relation.
The fact is just looking
at these phase-space plots,
you realize the angle
which we can determine here
for the photon distribution
will have quite a variance,
but now I want to
discuss with you
how would we
actually go about it,
how would we measure the
phase of the photon field?
And this requires a homodyne
experiment, a beat experiment
where we interfere the emitted
photon with a local oscillator,
which is the laser beam which
was used in the first place
to excite the atom.
And what we will find out,
and it's clear that we cannot
obtain a sharp
value of the phase,
but these fluctuations in the
phase do not come from any
partial trace, do not
come from any fluctuations
in the Hamiltonian.
Just to address that,
when we write down
the term in the Hamiltonian,
the e dot d term,
yes, depending on the
basis set, depending
how you define
spin up, spin down,
and what phase factors you
put into your basis set,
you may have a phase popping
up in the Hamiltonian,
but this phase is
purely definitional.
The phase I'm talking
about is really
a relative phase
between two amplitudes,
and it is independent
of a phase which
may be your choice by choosing
the basis set in which you
formulate the Hamiltonian.
Therefore, when we
measure the phase,
and we find that there
are fluctuations,
they actually come
form the quantum nature
of the states involved.
Let's talk about the
measurement and let
me set it up genetically.
Here is our atom, here
is the laser beam,
and we want to create a
Mach-Zehnder interferometer.
Let me just use another
color for the laser beam.
Why don't we take
sodium today, which
has emission in the orange?
The idea is the following.
We have a laser beam which
is used to excite the atom,
and here we have a switch.
And what we let through
is only a certain pulse.
Let's say if we want to have
a coherent superposition
between ground
and excited state,
it would be pi over 2 pulse.
Then, after the atom
has absorbed the pulse,
we switch off the light pass.
So then in the second
stage, the atom can emit,
and the emitted light interferes
with the local oscillator,
which is the laser beam, and
we can measure the beat node
on the detector.
This is the scheme how we
do a homodyne measurement.
And so we assume we have
a very short pulse which
excites the atom.
Then we switch off the laser
in the upper pass and the light
which reaches the
detector for homodyne
is only the light
which has been emitted
by the atom maybe
a nanosecond later.
So we do a homodyne measurement
of the phase of the wave
or the wave train
emitted by the atom.
And the distribution of
measurements for the phase,
I don't want to give you
mathematical expressions,
but it's pretty
much what you can
read from the drawing
I've shown you.
So for a pi over 2 pulse,
we retrieve the phase phi,
but with fluctuations.
Let's now come to
the interesting case
that we have a pi pulse.
The pi pulse prepares the
atom in an excited state,
and at t equals 0
after the excitation,
there's absolutely no coherence.
The density operator
for the atom
has just one in the column
and row for the excited state.
There's no off diagonal
matrix element.
There is no phase information.
So at t equals 0, no
coherence, no phase.
So now we have excited
the atom with a pi pulse,
but there is no
phase information
in the atomic system,
and that would also
mean that when we now
start mapping the quantum
state of the atom onto the
quantum state of the light,
there won't be any specific
phase for the light.
We could say after the
spontaneous emission is over
before we do any
measurement process,
we have mapped a flux state
of the atom onto a flux state,
n equals 1, of the
photon field, and there
is no phase associated
with a number state.
But let's be a little
bit more specific here.
Let's assume we can have
an ensemble of atoms,
we can repeat the
measurement many times,
and let's ask the question, what
happens after the atom which
was originally in the excited
state has decayed to 50%?
Well, then we have a
wave function which
is a superposition of
ground and excited state,
and there is a phase phi
now, but this phase phi
is completely random.
So for those of you who are
concerned that I call it a wave
function, you can
be more specific
in the sense of
quantum Monte Carlo,
that at any quantum Monte Carlo
wave function, at any given
moment you have a wave function,
but the ensemble of your atom
is now an ensemble
of all those wave
functions with a
random phase phi.
This is a way how
you can decompose
the statistical
operator of the system,
but the result is
the phase is random.
If the phase is random,
that means no coherence.
The statistical
operator does not
have an off diagonal
matrix element.
It also means that,
if you would ask
what is the ensemble average
of the dipole moment,
the dipole moment is
given by the Bloch vector.
Well, if all phases are equally
populated in your ensemble,
the dipole moment
average is 2-0.
But, of course, you
have a d squared value,
a value of the dipole
moment, which is not zero.
So here we have now a situation
where the photon field has
a random phase because
we lost the phase
information of the
laser beam when
we put the atom into
an excited state,
and you may now ask, what
is the origin of this phase
uncertainty?
And at least the
qualitative answer
is it's vacuum fluctuations.
You can take the concept
of vacuum fluctuations
a little bit further.
I'm just mentioning it,
but I will not work it out.
The fact that the phase of
this photon which is random
is somewhat associated
with vacuum fluctuations,
you can address this question
when you talk about two atoms.
So we have two atoms.
We excite them both with our
pi pulse into an excited state,
and then, as time
goes by, we will
have atoms which create photons.
And at least as
long as the atoms
are well localized within
optical wavelengths,
you could play with the
idea that if they're
vacuum fluctuations,
maybe the two atoms
will see the same
vacuum fluctuations.
And therefore, indeed, you will
actually observe correlations
in the relative phase.
So if you measure the phase of
the light emitted spontaneously
by the two atoms, you
will find a correlation
which is due to the fact that--
I'm waving my hands here,
but that the spontaneous
emission was triggered
by the same random
vacuum fluctuations.
So the absolute phase will be
completely random from time
to time, but the relative
phase will be correlated.
But what we are
talking about here
is correlations
between two atoms.
We will talk later
about superradiance,
and maybe this will
make it much clearer
what it means if several atoms
emit spontaneously together.
Any questions?
Yes, Colin?
AUDIENCE: Are there
any requirements
on these two atoms being located
within an optical wavelength
of each other?
PROFESSOR: Yes and no.
In the simplest example
of superradiance,
we want to put them to within
one optical wavelength,
and then we do not
have any phase vectors,
but we will talk about it
next week, that we also
have superradiance
in extended samples,
and then we only get the
superradiance, the coherence
between atoms, into
a smaller solid angle
where the are different
phases are very well defined.
If you would now average
the spontaneous emission
over different directions, you
would get propagation phases
and the atoms would only be
coherent in one solid angle
but not be coherent in
another solid angle.
Other questions?
That's, to the best
off my knowledge
at the most fundamental limit,
what spontaneous emission is,
how accurately a spontaneously
emitted photon carries forward
the phase of the laser beam
which excited the atom,
and then eventually when we
have completely lost the phase
because we excited the
atom to an excited state.
Everything that we discussed
will be actually carried
to the next level when
we discuss superradiance
because then we have n atoms--
n can be a big number-- which
excite together, and
if they emit photons,
the phase of this n photon field
can be very precisely measured.
So some of the
uncertainties we have here
simply come from the fact
that, if you have only one
photon or one atom,
there are naturally
quantum fluctuations of
any phase measurement.
But that part will go away when
we go to ensembles of atoms
where we have many atoms,
and superradiance is then
the way how we can
revisit the subject,
how well can you retrieve
the phase of the laser field
from the spontaneously
emitted photons.
Other questions?
Nancy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
single atom?
So pi over 2, I can see that
we do a homodyne measurement
and get the phase out.
Do we need dipole moments
for pi [INAUDIBLE], or this
is just a science
that we're going
to use for many other things?
PROFESSOR: What's the question?
We have pi over--
AUDIENCE: What
measurements do we
need if we have just one atom?
Do we make any measurements,
or no phase information?
PROFESSOR: I think the
measurement is, in a way,
what I indicated here.
We excite the atom, then
we switch off this pulse,
and then we take this
short pulse of light.
It's a wave train
which has a duration
on the order of the natural
lifetime of the atom,
and this wave
train is interfered
with a local oscillator,
and the interference term
allows us to retrieve the phase.
And if you use a strong
local oscillator,
then we pretty much
retrieve the quantum limit
of the measurement,
and the quantum limit
of the measurement
is what I showed you
in these cartoon drawings of
the phase-space distribution.
AUDIENCE: So essentially,
we can [? read a ?]
flux state like this?
PROFESSOR: If you
have a flux state
and you repeat the
measurement many times,
we will measure random phase.
So what happens here is--
let me put it this way.
The homodyne
detection is a way how
we want to measure the
phase, and whenever
you want to measure
the phase, you
get a phase because
the number you
get from a phase
measurement is a phase.
But if you have a
flux state which
has not a specific phase
but an equal probability
for all phases
between zero and 2 pi,
then, if you repeat a
phase measurement many,
many times, you will get a
random result for the phase.
AUDIENCE: I think that's what
my question originally was.
What measurement
would you perform
for this [? pi phase? ?]
Would you still do a phase
measurement?
PROFESSOR: It's your choice.
If you want to do a
phase measurement, that's
a way to do it, and
then for flux state,
you will get a random phase.
But maybe for the flux
state, of course, you
can say in hindsight, the flux
state doesn't have a phase
so maybe you shouldn't
bother measuring the phase.
The special thing
about the flux state
that it has exactly one
photon, and so maybe you
want to have a measurement
which is measuring
the special character
of the flux state,
namely that you have
sub-Poissonian distribution
of the photons.
Of course, this aspect of
just having one photon gets
completely lost when
you have a beam splitter
and you have zillions of
photons in your laser beam
with all the
Poissonian fluctuations
in the coherent state
and you superimpose it.
But this is nothing else
than complementarity.
You can either measure the phase
or you can measure the photon
number, and the question is,
what are you interested in?
This is one aspect of coherence
in a two level system,
namely that we have a phase
in the two level system
and the question is,
how can we measure it?
And the answer is we can
map it on the photon field
and then perform a quantum
measurement on the photon
field.
I want to continue with some
other aspect of coherence
in single atom.
Let me just point out
one important aspect
about coherence in
a two level system,
and this is related to something
very mundane, the precession
of spin-- when it's
a two level system,
it's spin 1/2-- in
a magnetic field.
In other words, I
just want to quickly
remind you in a few minutes
that for any two level system,
we can always map
it on spin 1/2.
I was really
emphasizing this message
throughout the whole course.
But for spin 1/2, if you
think of spin up or down
in a magnetic field, there
is a very clear visualization
of the coherence.
If you have a coherence of
position of spin up and down,
the phase of the
superposition decides
whether the spin
points in x or y.
So the precession of a spin
in the transverse xy plane
is actually the
manifestation of coherence,
and it's not just
the special coherence
of spin 1/2 in a magnetic
field because all two level
systems are isomorphic to that.
You can always use it as
an intuitive visualization
of what coherences are.
So what I just want to
point out is the relation
to the quantum mechanical
or classical precession
of spin in a magnetic
field, that it is simply
an effect of coherence
within one atom, coherence
between two levels in an atom.
So if spin points
in the x direction,
it is a coherent superposition
of plus z and minus z,
spin up and spin down, but
this is a situation at time t
equals 0.
If we let time evolve,
spin up and spin down
evolve with the Larmor
frequency, actually
effect of 1/2, but
with opposite phases
because one has plus the Larmor,
h bar omega Larmor over 2.
The other has minus h bar
omega Larmor over 2 as energy.
In other words, if you
look at the relative phase,
it's a beat node with
the same unsplitting
between spin up and spin down.
But that means now, due
to this coherent time
evolution of the two
amplitudes, that the spin
precesses in the xy plane.
The statistical operator
for the spin 1/2,
we have 50-50 population
in spin up and spin down,
but now, the phase
here precesses
as e to the minus
and e to the plus
i omega lt, which means, if you
use the statistical operator
and find the expectation
value for the x spin.
It means we take the
statistical operator describing
the pure state of
a two level system,
we multiply with a
Pauli matrix in x,
and this is a prescription
to get the expectation
value for sigma x, and we
find it's cosine omega lt.
So the spin is precessing
the x component changes
cosinusoidally.
That would mean the y
component changes sinusoidally.
Let me just contrast it to
the case of no coherence,
and this would mean off
diagonal matrix elements are 0.
then if you have a
statistical operator where
the off diagonal matrix elements
are zero, in one minute,
you can show that
then any expectation
value for the x or y component
of the spin vanishes.
In that case, if you have a
statistical mixer between spin
up and down, of course there
is no phase determined,
and it is the phase of
the superposition state
which tells you where
between 0 and 2 pi
the spin is pointing
in the xy plane.
I want to come
back later on when
I discuss an example of
coherent spectroscopy,
that if you excite coherently
a superposition of spin
up and spin down,
you can perform
some form of coherent
spectroscopy, which I want
to explain first in
general and then come back
to the spin as an example.
When we talk about
coherent spectroscopy,
I want to just in 10
minutes or 15 minutes
show you some spectroscopic
techniques which
exploit the coherence between
several quantum states.
I do it for a number of reasons.
One is coherent
spectroscopy actually
allows us to obtain information
about the level structure
even if this level structure is
much narrower than the Doppler
width.
So it is a sub-Doppler
technique to exploit coherence.
And before people had lasers,
before people invented
sub-Doppler laser
spectroscopy, often,
coherent spectroscopy
was the only way
how you could obtain detailed
structure of the atom.
The reason why I explain
coherent spectroscopy
is to just give you a little bit
idea about that you appreciate
how smart people were before
lasers were developed,
but also, it illustrates
what coherence can do for us.
It's a nice example for
the concept of coherence.
When I was a graduate
student, textbooks
had dozens of pages, 50 pages
on coherent spectroscopy,
the Hanle effect, quantum
beat measurements.
It's all old fashioned because
with a laser, and especially
cold atoms and the laser,
we have such wonderful tools
to go to the ultimate
fundamental precision
of quantum measurements.
But still, coherence
is important.
Let me talk about
one method, which
is called quantum
beat spectroscopy.
The selling point
about quantum beat
spectroscopy is that it allows
the measurement of narrow level
spacings-- just think
about Zeeman splitting
in a magnetic field-- without
any form of narrow band
excitation.
You can also put it like this.
If you don't have any way to
selectively excite levels,
but you're interested
what is the level spacing,
but you cannot have
a narrow band laser,
have atoms which stand still and
scan and get peak, peak, peak,
what you can still do is you can
just excite all of the levels
at once.
In other words, you hit
the atom with a board laser
like with a sledgehammer,
and then you see a beat node,
you see some blinking,
a quantum beat
between the excitation
of the levels.
That's the idea.
We assume we have a
ground state and then we
have an excited state manifold,
and in this excited state
manifold, we have several
levels distributed
over an energy interval delta.
Yes, we don't have a
narrow band source.
We may just have a
classic light source,
but if we use a short pulse
that the pulse duration is
much smaller than the splitting
between energy levels,
then we create a coherent
superposition of those levels.
So therefore, what
we create at time t
equals 0 is a
coherent superposition
of energy eigenlevels.
And the important thing is that
this is at time t equals 0,
but now, when time goes
on, each amplitude,
each part of the wave function,
evolves with its frequency
omega i, and if we would
then look at, let's say,
the emission spectrum
as a function of time,
we will find that-- I will give
you a little bit more details
later-- that yes, there
is a decay approximately
with the natural
spontaneous emission
time with the inverse of
the natural line widths.
But we observe some
oscillations which
is the interference term of
the different terms in the wave
function.
So therefore, if we
would take this spectrum
and perform a
Fourier transform, we
will actually observe
different peaks.
This is frequency, and
the frequency peaks
are at discrete frequencies
corresponding to frequency
differences between
the excited state.
And ideally, the
widths of these is
determined by the
natural line widths.
So in other words, what
we have actually done
is we have done a version of
the double slit experiment.
We have ground state, we
had our excited states,
e sub i, and our
broad band source
was creating a
coherent excitation,
and then we were observing
the light which came out.
We were performing a
multi-slit experiment.
We had a laser pulse and then
we see photons coming out,
but it is fundamentally
not observable
which intermediate state was
responsible for the scattering.
So therefore, we have
in the Feynman sense
several indistinguishable
paths going
through different
internal states.
And therefore, we get
an interference effect.
Some of what I'm
saying we will retrieve
later on when we talk
about three level systems.
We will also have
situations that sometimes we
go through two possibilities
for the intermediate state,
and if we have no way,
even in principle,
to figure out which
intermediate state was involved,
we have to sum up
the amplitudes,
and that's when we
get a beat node.
This technique is a
Doppler free technique
because, even if you
take a single pulse
from a light source, you have
a Doppler broadening, which
is k dot v, v, the
thermal velocity,
and this can be
much, much broader.
You will still see
the quantum beats,
maybe I should say in principle,
because the beat happens
at the much smaller
frequency delta.
Or maybe I should say that
the Doppler shift is reduced
by the splitting of the excited
states over the frequency
of the exciting laser.
Of course, if you have your
different atoms emitting
at different frequencies,
you have a Doppler shift,
but since you measure
the difference frequency,
you only get the Doppler shift
associated with the difference
frequency.
Now let me come back
to the previous example
I had about the spin 1/2 system.
If you assume you have a spin
1/2 system, spin up and spin
down, which is excited
with a laser, which
is linear polarization,
you would then
create a superposition of up
and down which, let's say,
is now a dipole moment which
points in the x direction.
A dipole moment which
points in the x direction
will not emit light along
the axis of the dipole moment
because of the dipolar
emission pattern.
It will only emit to the side.
But I mentioned to you that
the dipole moment or the spin,
which is originally
in x, will now
oscillate with a Larmor
frequency in the xy plane.
So the picture you
can actually have
of such a quantum beat
and quantum superposition
is like the lighthouse.
You have a searchlight
at the lighthouse,
and the searchlight
is just rotating
at the Larmor frequency.
For instance, you wouldn't
see light right now,
now you don't see light,
now you don't see light.
It's really like a
classical lighthouse
which is emitting light
at the Larmor frequency.
So if you have a
fluorescence detector which
looks at the atoms from
a certain direction,
you will pretty much see
the lighthouse effect
that the fluorescence of this
coherent superposition of atoms
goes on and off, on
and off, on and off.
This is sort of a very
nice visualization how
you obtain what I
showed here, a beat
node in your detected signal.
Let me talk about another
aspect of coherence.
And of course, they
are all related.
Coherence is always related
to the phase, to beat nodes,
to superposition.
Let me now talk about
one aspect which
is related to delayed detection.
When I was a graduate
student and I
learned about spectroscopic
techniques, somehow
I was so fascinated
by techniques
which could measure
spectroscopically transitions
better than the
natural line widths.
I don't know.
Maybe from what I
had read before,
what I learned as
an undergraduate,
the natural line
widths appeared to be
the natural fundamental limit.
So the topic I'm
teaching right now
has always had a certain
fascination for me,
but you will, of course,
also realize that in the end,
the answer is rather simple.
Once you know the answer,
most answers are very simple.
So we want to talk
about delayed detection.
Let's say we excite the system.
You can think about a
quantum beat experiment.
You have a short pulse and
then your quantum beats happen.
And now the question
is, normally,
when you do a measurement
on a decaying system,
you're always limited by
the natural line widths,
by the inverse of the lifetime.
But now, maybe you
want to be smart
and you say, well, I start the
detection, I only detect atoms
after a time t0, which
is much, much larger
than the natural line widths.
And the question
I have is, can you
obtain, with such a measurement,
a spectral resolution which
is narrower than the
natural line widths?
Well, we can give
two possible answers.
One is yes, because
you're looking
at atoms which have survived
for a long time, so to speak.
These atoms are longer lived.
We have just
selected atoms which
happened to survive
for several lifetimes.
But then there should
some lingering doubts.
If you have a sample which
undergoes radioactive decay,
and you would go to
your favorite supplier
and buy uranium,
which has already
decayed for a
billion years, it's
the same uranium which
existed a billion years ago.
You will not be able to
perform any measurement
on your well aged uranium,
which has a higher
resolution than if you had
lived a billion years ago
and had done your measurement
with younger uranium.
So in other words,
the exponential decay
is self similar.
It starts at any moment
and it looks exponential
no matter where you start.
I didn't bring clickers
today, but with which
answer would you side?
Is it possible or
it's not possible?
Maybe just hints
of who thinks it
is possible by taking advantage
of the longtime survivors?
OK.
Who thinks it's impossible?
A few.
Good.
The answer is actually depends.
If you would go and just look
at the longtime survivors,
you would not be able to do
a more precise measurement.
You need a little
bit of information
from the earlier time.
So in that sense, the question
is a little bit deliberately
confusing, and I want to show
you how the mathematics work.
It's just five minutes to show
the mathematics of a Fourier
transform, and
the result will be
if you have information about
something at t equals 0,
and then you look at the long
time survivors, you in essence
have a longer integration
period for your measurement,
and then the Fourier
transform of that measurement
can be very narrow.
But if you do the dumb thing,
you just go to the store
and buy very well aged uranium
or very well aged atoms,
and you then start
your measurement,
you have no chance.
You are always back to
the spontaneous decay
to the natural line widths.
All I have to do is
actually just a few lines
of mathematics and
Fourier transform.
Let us assume we have the
situation we discussed earlier.
We have a quantum beat where we
have a beat frequency omega 0.
Just think about the
searchlight, the atoms which
oscillate with a
Larmor frequency,
and you have some
cosine omega Larmor t
factor in the intensity
of the light you observe.
But now, because the atom in
the excited state is decaying,
everything will decay with
the natural line width.
This is sort of what we
observe, and the question
is, if you observe
that in real time,
can we then retrieve
spectral information from it
which is more
accurate than gamma?
All I want to do is I want
to discuss the Fourier
transform of this
function, s of t.
Let me use
dimensionless variables.
We measure frequencies
in units of gamma.
We use a Lorentzian, which
is just 1 plus x squared.
We just said we want to start
the measurement at time t0.
So the question is, if you
start later and later and later,
do we get higher
accuracy because we're
talking to the survivors?
So let's perform the
Fourier transform,
and let's use complex
notation, e to the i omega t.
I will measure times in units
of the inverse line widths.
So we performed the
Fourier transform,
and by doing e to the
i omega t, I actually
performed the Fourier transform
for the cosine and for the sine
by using the real part
and the imaginary part
of the complex number.
So we will actually
be able to look
at the real and imaginary part.
The Fourier transform has
a real and imaginary part,
so let me call the real part
F of x and the imaginary part
G of x.
You can do the math.
It's a straightforward integral.
In both cases, will we find
that if you do our measurement,
well, the longer we wait,
the more signal we lose.
This is common to all
delayed measurements.
You're really now talking
to an exponentially smaller
and smaller signal.
Also, because of the
exponential decay,
we get an envelope
which is a Lorentzian.
But then, and this is
the interesting part,
we have cosine xT
minus x sine xT.
So now we have factors
which depend on capital T,
and t is larger
the longer we wait.
It is actually those
parts with sine and cosine
which determine whether
we can get resolution
below the natural line widths.
What is important
is-- and this should
be sort of an eye
opener for you--
if you simply measure intensity,
if you look at the power
spectrum, you take the real part
plus imaginary part and just
look at the absolute
value, then,
because of cosine squared
plus sine squared equals 1,
all the cosine and sine part,
the last part of the expression
above cancels out
and you find that you
have an exponential
loss of signal
but your spectral distribution
is always a Lorentzian.
So you always have a Lorentzian
line shape completely
independent of the
delay time, capital T.
And this is what some
of you maybe thought.
If I start the
measurement later and all
I can do is look at the
power of the emitted light,
I have no advantage.
I cannot go sub-natural.
However, if you
look at the function
F of x for large values of
x, you find oscillations.
So if you look at the sine
or cosine Fourier transform,
the real or imaginary
part separately,
you find oscillations,
and those oscillations,
similar to Ramsey fringes,
have a central peak.
The central peak is
narrow and the width
is now given by not the
inverse of the natural lifetime
but the inverse
of the delay time
you wait for your measurement.
So the fact is now we
had a signal s of t which
we assumed was a quantum beat
with a well defined phase,
and then it was
exponentially decaying.
If we would now perform
a Fourier transform where
we do a Fourier transform
with cosine omega t plus phi,
we can get a narrow signal,
but we have no idea what phi is
or if, in repetitions
of the experiment,
phi would be random, then this
is sort of what the math does.
If phi is random, it is the
same as if we simply measure
the power spectrum because
we cannot distinguish between
the cosine and sine
Fourier transform.
So if the phase
phi is random, that
means you only measure
what was F plus IG before.
In other words, the situation
is extremely in the end
very simple.
If you have quantum
beats which start
with a well defined phase,
and you know the phase was,
let's say, zero here, and now
you have the decaying function,
and now you look at the
quantum beat over there, well,
in a way, you had
n beats between t
equals 0 and your
measurement, and then
your resolution
goes with 1 over n,
but you have to know what
the phase was at t equals 0,
and then, by looking
at delayed detection,
you can do spectroscopy below
the natural line widths.
So therefore, what
is crucial here
is knowledge, or at
least reproducibility,
of the phase phi, and then
you can get narrow lines.
Examples for techniques where
you excite the system at t
equals 0 and then you
can do delayed detection
of quantum beats.
I mentioned earlier
in the course
the Ramsey spectroscopy where
you have one Ramsey zone where
you prepare your Bloch vector.
Then the Bloch
vector oscillates,
and if you simply look at the
phase angle of the Bloch vector
after a very long time, you
have very high precision
but you're dealing with an
exponentially small signal.
Another example are heterodyne
or homodyne techniques,
but you need something which
is phase sensitive in order
to obtain sub-natural
line widths.
A final comment is if you
want to get higher resolution
with delayed detection,
yes, you can get it,
but you was
exponentially in signal.
And what does it
mean in practice?
Well, if you know
your line shape,
you know it's well
described by a Lorentzian,
it is better to take
your full signal
and use then an
excellent signal to noise
to find the line center
and split the line.
However, if there's
any ambiguity,
there may be different,
not fully resourced lines
under the Lorentzian
and you don't
know how to split the
line, then it may be better
to do delayed
detection and clearly
see the structure of the lines
with sub-natural resolution.
Any questions?
This was coherence with two
levels, coherent excitation,
coherent observation, some
spectroscopic techniques.
Now we are ready to do
the next step, namely,
to talk about coherence
in three level systems.
If we have three levels,
we could think about it,
we have terms which
connect level one to two,
level two to three,
and level three to one
in all possible
ways, but that's not
what we want to assume here.
The situation where we can
discuss some fundamentally new
effects is when we have
two states connected
through a third state.
In other words, if
we have two levels,
we are not allowing any
transition matrix element
connecting the two.
They are only connected
through a third state.
This is for obvious reasons
called the lambda type system.
You can turn it upside down
and you have the V type system
or, if the intermediate
state is between the first
and the second state, you
have a ladder type system.
But once you start driving
it, it may not really matter.
There may be a dressed
atom description
where, if you drive two states
coherently in the dressed atom
picture, you have degeneracy
between this level
and one more photon
and this level.
And then in the
dressed atom picture,
which includes a
number of photons,
the two levels have
become degenerate.
So therefore, it's
very important
for practical applications
or how to implement it
in an atom what kind
of system you have,
but for the description
of those systems,
some of the
differences may simply
disappear if you formulate
it in the dressed atom basis.
Of course, there's an
important practical reason.
Usually the lower states
are ground states,
the upper states
are excited states.
And here you have the
opportunity, and that's
why the lambda type system
is the most important one,
to have some coherent
superposition mediated
by the third state, and
the coherent superposition
is stable because it's
a coherent superposition
of ground states.
If any form of
coherent superposition
involves an excited state, then
you have short lived states,
and they are often not so
useful for certain phenomena.
So if you think you know already
everything about how atoms
interact with light
from two level atoms,
I have to tell you that's not
the case because a three level
system has many new effects.
One, of course, is
that atoms can now
interact with two
electromagnetic fields,
and those two electromagnetic
fields can affect each other,
and this can happen through
coherent or incoherent
mechanisms.
In other words, you
can say it simply.
If you hit an atom with light
and you have a two level
system, there is no way
how the atom can hide.
It's always excited
by the laser.
But if you have a
three level system,
you may have a
situation where you
have destructive interference
between what the two lasers can
do to the atom,
and suddenly, there
may be a state where the atom is
in the dark where the atom can
hide from the laser beam.
This is something which
is fundamentally new
and has no counterpart
in a two level system.
I've already pointed out
that the lambda system
is the most important one
because it has two ground
states which can be in a long
lived superposition state.
What we want to discuss as
possible consequences is that
in a three level system, you
can realize a lasing operation
without having inversion
of the population
of the ground and excited state.
So if you always thought,
if I want to build a laser,
the first thing I
have to do is make
sure I have more atoms in the
excited than in the ground
state, yes, this is valid
for two level system,
but it is no longer valid
for a three level system.
The reason why you want to
invert a two level system
is you want to have stimulated
emission from the excited
state which is stronger
than absorption
from the ground state.
But if you take advantage
of quantum coherence,
you may have a situation
where two possibilities
for stimulated emission
add up coherently,
but the two possibilities
for absorption
add up destructively.
And therefore, you
can avoid destruction.
You have only
stimulated emission,
but you have not achieved
that through inversion.
You have achieved that
through quantum coherence,
a fundamentally new effect.
So we have lasing
without inversion,
we have the phenomenon
I mentioned already
that atoms can hide in the
dark if the two laser beams
in the excitation mechanism
destructively interfere.
This is called
electromagnetically induced
transparency.
Systems which have sharp
resonances in three level
systems are used for reducing
the group velocity of light,
which goes under the
name slowing light,
or even bringing light to a
standstill, stopping light.
And three level
systems are also used
for quantum mechanical memories
for quantum computation.
Any questions?
This is an introduction.
Let me connect special effects
in a three level system
to something which is very
basic and you've heard about it,
and this is optical pumping.
If we set up a system which
has two ground states, g and f,
you may just think about
two hyperfine states
in your favorite atom,
and then they are only
coupled through
an excited state,
you can now drive the
system with laser fields
omega 1 and omega 2.
Let me also use that
example of optical pumping
to introduce some notation
which I will need to describe
the system with a few equations.
We will use energy
level diagrams,
and the energy is referred
to the lowest ground state.
So here, we have an energy
splitting which is by omega gf,
and the excited state
has a splitting of eg.
We will call the photons in
one laser the photons created
and annihilated with the
operator a and a dagger,
and for the photons for
the other laser beam,
we use c or c dagger.
Now, there is a
very simple solution
for this situation, a very
simple equilibrium situation,
if you have only one laser beam.
If you have only one laser
beam, omega 1 or omega 2,
it's clear what happens.
If you have only one laser
beam, let's say omega 1,
it doesn't talk at all to
the atoms in the state f.
They are left alone.
But the atoms in the state g are
excited to the excited state,
and then there may be a
certain branching ratio
for spontaneous emission,
but let's rather call it
fluorescence, two
photon scattering.
So there be a branching ratio
to go back to that state
or to go to the state f.
If the latter happens,
the atom doesn't
interact with the
laser light anymore.
If it goes back to
the original state,
the atom will try again and
again until after a while,
all the atoms have been
optically pumped into the state
f.
And the same would happen if
you have a laser, omega 2,
then you would pump all
the atoms into the state g.
So if you have only one laser
beam, omega 1 and omega 2,
then in equilibrium, the
equilibrium population
is 100% of the atoms are in
state f or g respectively,
and this is nothing
else than the phenomenon
of optical pumping.
We have a very simple solution.
We pump all the atoms
into one quantum state
if we have only one
of the laser beams.
But the question is now, can
we have a similar situation
when both laser beams are on?
And what I mean by
that is, is it possible
now to pump all the atoms
into a state which does not
scatter any light, which does
not react with the light, which
is never excited to
the excited state?
The answer is yes,
and this is what
we want to derive right now.
Before I go into any equation,
the result is pretty clear.
If you have, say, g and f
and they are both excited,
if the amplitude which you
put into the excited state
is the same but
has opposite sign,
the two amplitudes which
are added in a time delta t
destructively interfere
and you have not
put any amplitude into
the excited state.
And that means, if you have
this initial superposition
state where this complete
destructive interference
happened, this state will
be dark all the time.
But we want to assume--
also it doesn't matter--
that the two states,
the two lasers
have two different frequencies.
So you cannot say, this is just
the two lasers have a certain
phase and then the laser field
interferes and they reach
a space which is dark.
We assume that the atom
is sitting at the origin.
Again, we're not putting
in motion effects,
so it's an atom
with infinite mass.
Then we shine two
laser lights on it
and the atom is not in the dark.
It's not at a dark fringe of the
interference of the two laser
beams because if you have
two laser beams with two
different frequencies,
there will not
be any place in space
which is dark all the time.
You create maybe
interference fringes,
but the interference
fringes are rapidly
running with a beat node,
omega 1 minus omega 2.
So the atom is not in the
dark, but nevertheless, it
will not scatter light
if it is prepared
in a suitable coherent
superposition state.
We describe this situation
with a dipole Hamiltonian,
and we make the rotating
wave approximation.
The Hamiltonian has
three lines, three parts.
One is we describe each of the
laser fields as a single mode.
I call the frequency
now omega a and omega c,
just to connect it with
the operator c dagger, c.
For the atom, we use the
matrix, two by two matrices,
so this is the matrix if the
atom is in the ground state.
Coherences are
described by that.
And of course, without any
interaction with the laser
field, the atomic Hamiltonian is
atoms are in the ground state.
the state f has zero energy.
We use that as the
origin of the energy.
The state g has an
eigenenergy of omega gf,
and the excited state e has
an eigenenergy of omega ef.
But now the important
part is that we
want to have the coupling.
And actually, I realized I
was not saying it correctly.
Omega 1 and omega 2, these are
the Rabi frequencies of the two
fields, and the two fields are
at frequency omega a and omega
c.
So now we have the coupling
between the excited state
and the ground state via
photons a and a dagger.
And the coupling happens at
the Rabi frequency omega 1.
And then we have the
second laser field,
which is at Rabi
frequency omega 2.
We have the atomic raising
and lowering operator,
and we have the
photon c and c dagger.
That's a nice Hamiltonian.
It has three lines.
The important part here, which
we have explicitly assumed
is that each of the lasers, a
and a dagger, c and c dagger,
are only driving one transition.
One field is responsible
for connecting the state f
to the excited state.
The other field is responsible
for connecting the state
g to the excited state.
In practice, this
can be accomplished
by you have maybe polarization.
This is a plus one state,
this is a minus one state,
and the excited
state is m equals 0.
Then one laser
beam is sigma plus,
the other one is sigma
minus, so it can be polarized
and the two laser
beams can only talk
to one of the ground states.
Or you can have a situation
that you have a huge energy
separation.
Let's say you have a
large hyperfine splitting
and the two lasers are
separated by frequency.
I think I've set the stage,
but I think I should stop here
and on Wednesday, I'll show
you in the first few minutes
of the class that
this Hamiltonian has
a simple solution, which
is a dark state, which
is a superposition
state of g and f.
Any questions?
See you on Wednesday.
A few people haven't picked
up their midterm quizzes.
If you want them,
I have them here.